and they're not just doing it in one
state and folks i've been [ __ ] saying
this i've been telling you this and
doubt me on this i even tweeted it here
um there won't be a civil war there they
will steal your democracy away from the
inside that is exactly what they plan on
doing that exactly what they want that's
why steve bannon needs to be in [ __ ]
handcuffs in a jail cell because him
yapping his trap and convincing these
people to do this is what is happening
doubt me doubt me on it there's not
gonna be no [ __ ] civil war
they're not gonna win by doing violence
in the streets where they're gonna take
over a country in each [ __ ] county
each election office every single state
come on give me a [ __ ] break what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to steal our elections from the inside
you know that [ __ ] they talk about how
democrats stole the 2020 election they
rigged it that's what they're doing
that is what they're trying to do folks
they're [ __ ] delusional
and it's dangerous as [ __ ] and i'm not
talking about violence and riots and the
[ __ ] they're trying to distract us with
to try to scare you about a bunch of
[ __ ] gravy seals
going rogue in the streets that's not
what i'm talking about
i'm talking about them actually stealing
your [ __ ] way of life away from you
stealing your [ __ ] freedom because
that's what they're doing they're trying
to steal your freedom and every
american's freedom along with it watch
this report from cnn new day
i know i know cnn has taken a turn here
but they must again they must have had
this reporting racked up before they
really started to go full on trump
because this does not spell trump and
maybe our pushback
the last few weeks
has led them to air this this story
watch
now to a cnn exclusive video showing
election workers being trained by
republican leaders in michigan to break
the rules so they can act as quote
undercover agents during the midterm
elections in november
you heard that right
you heard that right they're training
republicans manga republicans
to be secret agents to be spies
i'm not [ __ ] [ __ ] you here they
say it out loud this it's not like this
is [ __ ] some kind of conspiracy
theory these people are holding meetings
and discussing in zoom [ __ ] calls how
to steal our elections
through the elections
these people have lost their goddamn
minds watch drew griffin joins us live
with this cnn investigation this is
incredibly alarming drew
doubly troubling brianna because this
becomes amid a big nationwide push by
this ultra mega crowd to get involved in
the election the people who didn't
believe the last election was fair for
some reason still are now getting
involved in running this election which
is why what you're about to see
is troubling
well don't be fearful guys cnn obtained
this recording of a wayne county gop
training session over zoom the night
before the michigan primary last month
so you're all really undercover agents
congratulations just undercover training
they're undercover agents
they're having a [ __ ] zoom call where
they're talking about people watching
election officials and they're
undercover agents they're there to
destroy
they're there to thwart
your democracy your vote this is your
vote they're [ __ ] talking about
this is real life [ __ ] this isn't
[ __ ]
wrestling
this isn't [ __ ] football this isn't
the goddamn baseball game
this is real [ __ ] life
and these people are coming after the
lgbt community in tennessee they want to
marry your [ __ ] children they're
coming after women's rights and freedoms
everywhere including to their body and
to their medical decisions
and it won't stop there it'll go to
contraception it'll go to men's
contraception it'll go to what religion
you can and cannot have doubt me
doubt me
and they're trying to work this is the
civil war folks this is it
ain't no [ __ ] there ain't gonna be no
fat dudes with ar-15s in the streets
gonna take over our government you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
you think a bunch of gravy seals have
any chance against our military against
our country you are a dumb [ __ ]
if you think that's where this is
happening they're trying to steal your
[ __ ] government and they're doing it
from the inside
it gets worse i'm telling you it gets
way worse it is extra training partisan
training not just for volunteers
observing elections but including the
actual paid election workers who will
check in voters hand out ballots even
help in the county which is that's right
the people that are going to count your
[ __ ] vote are being trained how to
overthrow a government how to overthrow
an election
on zoom calls
they're organizing and training traitors
that's what they're doing this isn't
democracy
this is them using our vote to take away
our democracy to use the election system
to take away our democracy the way they
do in russia
they act like they got some kind of
[ __ ] election system in russia
there's no goddamn election system in
russia
it's all for show that's what they want
to do they want to have it for show and
exactly what mike lindell
michael flynn sydney powell
donald trump and the rest of those
[ __ ] mogollonites have been accusing
democrats of doing
that's what they're currently
doing
that's what they're doing it's all
projection and they're doing it right
now they're trying to get inside those
elections
and i know it feels like oh what what
can we do
you have to lean into your democracy
you can't you can't go oh well my vote's
not going to count so i'm not going to
go vote because it definitely won't
count if you don't vote it definitely
won't count if you don't engage if you
don't make sure people are registered if
you don't make sure people go and and
use their power of their voice with
their vote
because democrats sure as hell have a
hell of a lot better teams to know what
election laws are
the smart republicans here have left the
[ __ ] party they've left smart
republicans wouldn't engage in state and
federal crimes to try to overthrow
elections they wouldn't do it
if they were smart they're not they're
manga republicans they're [ __ ] cult
members
they're trump lodites maglites
boneheads
we have good people on our side in the
democrat party
who are going to protect
our vote and try everywhere to protect
our vote but you must
you must engage in your ballot that's
why what they are being told is alarming
there's a lot of bad stuff that's
happening in this upcoming election so
we're gonna have to keep our heads on a
swivel and just start documenting
irregularities look we're not even to
the election yet we're two months away
from it and there's already bad stuff
what the [ __ ] does that mean
there's not even early voting i mean
there will be soon but there's not even
early voting at this point how in the
hell could there be bad stuff happening
in these elections
other than you people trying to
overthrow them before we even vote and
that's what they really want folks
that's what they want they want to
determine these elections before you
even cast a ballot
the poll workers are hired by towns and
clerks and wayne county's republican
chairperson cheryl costantino tells them
they may need to break the rules to
uncover fraud they were told by their
trainers that they could not have their
funds with them so i would say maybe
just hide it and maybe hide a small pad
and a small pen you need to take
accurate notes
so here she is telling them hide your
phones hide your notes because they'll
take them away from you they'll take
them away from you just hide them just
you know
don't listen to the rules don't listen
to the rule of law don't listen to any
of that cheat
cheat in your elections that's the only
way we'll win that's what they're saying
here
and these people are buying this stuff
well this guy this next guy doesn't
quite buy it watch take accurate notes
if we are observed with a pen and a
piece of paper writing on anything they
they just said they would they would ask
us that they would
that's right they would remove us
because it's against the rules to do
that you're just observing
you're just watching you're a watcher to
make sure democracy the election workers
aren't doing what you're saying you want
to do how can they not [ __ ] see the
forest through the trees here it's
because they're in a [ __ ] cult
they're in a [ __ ] cult
and just like we talked with jim
stewards and yesterday they are
absolutely mind [ __ ] here
they're so mind [ __ ] that they got
this whole thing turned around on
themselves
that's why you gotta do it secretly this
training for the primary was just
practice for the upcoming midterms
according to constantino and it's not
just what's being taught it's who is
doing the teaching this is super
important watch who they're having talk
to these [ __ ] people watch heather
who who they're having mind [ __ ]
brainwash these people into thinking the
only way to make sure your elections
aren't stolen is to steal them
yourselves
i'm dead serious listen we think a lot
of the monkey business that's happening
is happening at the vote aggravation
location that is election denier patrick
kobeck who co-led this training session
he's a former state senator who wrote a
book called the 2020 coup and has oh
there was a 2020 coup attempt
there was one but you [ __ ] got
your head so far up your ass you don't
know what
[ __ ] from shinola at this point blog
filled with debunked conspiracy theories
about voting machines he spread so much
disinformation about the 2020 election
he got this cease and desist letter from
dominion the voting machine company
saying you are knowingly sowing discord
in our democracy all the while
soliciting exorbitant amounts of money
all right well first of all he's
appeared on steve bannon's show
okay so right there he's appeared on
steve bannon's trader tv news network
think about that for a second
steve bannon was was arrested and
charged yesterday
with
with fraud
with defrauding the very people that
this guy is defrauding
now you talk about a fraud here's the
next [ __ ] my pillow my slipper nazi
let's watch he's on his [ __ ] [ __ ] too
and with the my pillow guy mike lindell
we did see evidence that it was
connected to the internet there is no no
no
they were not connected to the internet
and it is all [ __ ]
it's all nonsense it's [ __ ] lies and
again the guy
sitting next to steve bannon who steve
bannon yesterday was arraigned on
charges in the state of new york for
defrauding the same people this guy's
trying to defraud
it's absolutely batshit crazy
evidence any voting machines were
connected to the internet in the 2020
election but kobeck is still asking
republican poll workers to check there's
this little icon down the bottom right
hand corner and what i'm trying to do is
to see whether or not these machines are
indeed connected to the internet
no you're not that's not what you're
trying to do you're trying to thwart
people's idea that democracy exists
is what they're trying to do folks
they're trying to see if they can
convince not just their supporters but
the entire country or the majority of
the country that democracy doesn't
really exist
because once it's if you believe that
democracy doesn't really exist it's not
a thing then when it's taken from you
it's something you don't miss
it's not a big deal i mean we didn't
have democracy anyways
that's what they're trying to do from
the inside that's where the civil war is
happening not out in the streets with a
bunch of fat dudes and black jackets
and peashooters now
that's not what's gonna happen this is
the civil war
kobeck refused to speak to cnn but the
other leader of the training cheryl
constantino did
this is beautiful here this is words out
of their own [ __ ] mouths this lady
here this lady here is the one who was
telling them
to be secret agents to be spies
to make sure to thwart our democracy
to overturn our elections
is what they're telling these folks on
these zoom calls to do
this is that lady this is her right here
listen to what she says it is [ __ ]
crazy
training these people to be undercover
spies that was the words you were using
and i'm wondering why
well
first of all
if you remember in the election two
years ago
now this lady um
is the chair
she's the chair she's the head of the
wayne county gop in michigan
now the other guy's in atlanta
this just isn't in michigan though folks
you know what they're doing this [ __ ]
right here
tucked away in wayne galley michigan
they're doing it all over the country
and if you think him being on steve
bannon's show is just happenstance that
these [ __ ] steve bannon and
donald trump and the like don't have
something to do with this you're outside
your [ __ ] mind you're outside your
mind
the my pillow guy steve bannon and this
this woman but with the guy
who's telling people who's sewing
anti-democracy discord
throughout the gop
deluding brainwashing mind [ __ ] manga
republicans
into believing
that the [ __ ]
that they're telling them democrats are
doing they're actually convincing them
to do themselves
watch
there were so many problems with
election staffing she said with who
counted ballots but she's an election
denier too she filed a baseless lawsuit
in detroit alleging election fraud in
2020 it was thrown out why did she tell
election workers to act like spies to
kind of reframe it and make it more fun
and
interesting oh it's professional
wrestling now again i say this all the
time we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life these
[ __ ] know it they've got all
these people brainwashed into thinking
that it's just all fun and games it's
not fun and games it's not
this is our [ __ ] way of life our
entire country's foundation
is built
on the respective elections the entire
thing the entire democracy
is built on the foundation that we have
integrity in our democracy integrity in
our vote and yes is there some fraud
some places absolutely we're seeing it
right here in front of your eyes
the gop the maga republicans
the america first nazi party
wants
to tear down
your way of life and they want to take
away your democracy because if they can
erode your democracy from within they
can really take away your liberty look
what they did with roe i mean jesus
christ it took him a long time to buy
and pay for all those supreme court
justices but they finally got it done
they finally were able to use our system
of democracy
to take away women's liberty to take
away women's freedom and they won't stop
there they're not going to stop there
i said just you know instead of causing
a bunch of scenes and things like that
just write it down just kind of be like
spies and let me
you know let me know what's going on
what
be like spies gabe sanchez she wants
these people to be like spies and tell
her what's going on in these elections
this is [ __ ] crazy have you watched
it
no i have not seen this god this is nuts
you gotta go back and watch this i've
been showing our audience i wanted to
get to this this is cnn reporting this
which is you know regardless of what you
think maybe they had it on the slate
before they took a hard right turn or
maybe maybe just maybe they saw the
pushback from last week they're like ah
that whole maga thing you might not want
to do that and they go against it
we're holding zoom meetings to teach
election workers how to thwart our
democracy they're literally telling them
to be secret agents and spies that's
what they're telling them watch
michigan's primary election went
smoothly i did nothing wrong a poll
challenger affiliated with kolbeck and
his training was thrown out of detroit's
ballot counting center for repeatedly
getting too close to workers i told them
that they were breaking the law what's
happening in michigan is happening
across the nation attempts are underway
to make sure the ultra mega run the
election process from poll workers all
the way up to candidates for secretary
of state and attorney general and this
is what i've been saying gabe this is
what i've been saying the civil war is
not in the streets you're not gonna have
fat toothless dudes with in trump pants
beating our military at some sort of
violent overthrow of the government it's
not gonna happen we watched this on
january 6th
it's just not going to happen yeah they
tried it
their attempt to steal away our
democracy
is inside our government and when steve
bannon is meeting with this guy who's
going on these meetings to tell these
people how to [ __ ] cheat in our
elections it makes me suspicious that
the guy who just got handcuffed for
defrauding trump supporters is teaching
another guy how to defraud trump
supporters and steal our elections at
the same time i'm sorry i'm just trying
to make sense of this so you're telling
me that the people that complain about
people cheating
yeah that's what they want to do yeah
okay okay just want to make sure i mean
projection
i mean you never have to guess that's
the that's the that's the craziest part
about this whole exercise that we're
going through right now in our country
with misinformation disinformation with
mind [ __ ] like we talked with jim
stewartson yesterday
is that it really is right out in the
open like it's obvious that they're
projecting everything that they accuse
democrats of is [ __ ] they wanted to do
and what to do to steal elections
that's exactly what they were telling us
they were like hey if we were to steal
the election
this is how we would do it and how we
plan on doing it like literally that's
what they would do
but you know who's who's to really point
the finger here no i know no one no one
should be pointing the finger at them
because they right clearly they're the
victim tony right they frankly are the
victim you know and there's no more
projection than that exact statement
let's continue
trump attorney cleta mitchell has led
seminars in eight swing states all under
the presumption democrats cheat cnn
caught up with her in wisconsin that
we'll be able to
make sure that there's um there's
another set of eyes going on uh watching
the ballots watching the voting watching
the process knowing what's going on in
the election offices
okay so
you know kalita mitchell mitchell is do
you remember her name on the january 6
select hearings
um yeah she was one of the ones she was
one of the attorneys all up in trump's
ear about how you can and can't steal a
democracy i believe clayton mitchell is
from arizona i believe or nevada one of
those states i'm not real sure but here
she is in wisconsin they caught up with
her in wisconsin [ __ ] going
around the country telling people how to
steal elections yes and this is jeff
this is jeff timmer let's let's listen
to his response he used to be the
michigan chair
the same position that the lady who's
telling people to be spies
one of the same types of positions he
was the state chair not the county these
uh training sessions are planned chaos
these people
are being radicalized jeff chimmer used
to lead the michigan republican party
they think they're saving
democracy
from the cannibal socialists where in
fact what they're doing
is
eroding the public's faith in in
elections
brianna secretary of state's
particularly in michigan they're
preparing for whatever might come up but
there is a bright spot in this and
that's from the town clerks that
actually run these elections
they say that most of this election
denialism is coming out of ignorance and
once they get these volunteers and
employees in there even suspicious ones
and they see how the system works they
actually become believers in how we vote
in this country so
hopefully
smell [ __ ] well i mean you know he's
he's trying to make a strong case here
for why why this isn't such a big deal
but it is a big deal yeah and even if
they're pretending because i think
that's what you're saying like they're
like oh yeah sure i believe in it well
they say they believe it and they're
like oh well if they see it then it's
like oh i'm more likely to participate
in the actual process of voting like the
actual act of of democracy and there i i
somehow don't believe that
if i were to if i were to look
at a group of people that were
manipulating the votes or manipulating
the outcome or influencing the outcome
i don't know if i would have the most
amount of faith to participate
necessarily like some people will be
like oh [ __ ] this i'm going to vote but
some people might be like well if
they're already
manipulating or influencing the election
then what am i one person going to do
right so well you know i think this is
the actual um
the disappointment that i have about the
georgia case that they're bringing uh in
in georgia against people who were
trying to to overturn the election there
after the fact um because i think if
more of that would come to light and i
think that's what lindsey graham and
rudy giuliani they're trying to stall
because they know they're not this story
that what happened in georgia isn't
going to come out until after the
election which is good for them because
they can get all these people to commit
crimes for them these people are going
to be committing
crimes on behalf
of the maga republican party